and the label considers this a failure.
I was like, "25,000, isn't that a lot?"
They said, "No, the sales are going down.
It's a failure."
And they walk off.
Right at this same time, I'm signing and hugging after a gig,
and a guy comes up to me
and hands me a $10 bill,
and he says,
"I'm sorry, I burned your CD from a friend."
(Laughter)
"But I read your blog, I know you hate your label.
I just want you to have this money."
And this starts happening all the time.
I become the hat after my own gigs,
but I have to physically stand there and take the help from people,
and unlike the guy in the opening band,
I've actually had a lot of practice standing there.
Thank you.
And this is the moment I decide
I'm just going to give away my music for free
online whenever possible,
so it's like Metallica over here, Napster, bad;
Amanda Palmer over here,
and I'm going to encourage torrenting, downloading, sharing,
but I'm going to ask for help,
because I saw it work on the street.
So I fought my way off my label, and for my next project
with my new band, the Grand Theft Orchestra,
I turned to crowdfunding.
And I fell into those thousands of connections that I'd made,
and I asked my crowd to catch me.
And the goal was 100,000 dollars.
My fans backed me at nearly 1.2 million,
which was the biggest music crowdfunding project to date.
(Applause)
And you can see how many people it is.
It's about 25,000 people.
And the media asked,
"Amanda, the music business is tanking and you encourage piracy.
How did you make all these people pay for music?"
And the real answer is, I didn't make them.
I asked them.
And through the very act of asking people,
I'd connected with them,
and when you connect with them, people want to help you.
It's kind of counterintuitive for a lot of artists.
They don't want to ask for things.
But it's not easy.
It's not easy to ask.
And a lot of artists have a problem with this.
Asking makes you vulnerable.
And I got a lot of criticism online,
after my Kickstarter went big,
for continuing my crazy crowdsourcing practices,
specifically for asking musicians
who are fans if they wanted to join us on stage
for a few songs in exchange for love and tickets and beer,
and this was a doctored image that went up of me on a website.
And this hurt in a really familiar way.
And people saying,
"You're not allowed anymore to ask for that kind of help,"
really reminded me of the people in their cars yelling, "Get a job."
Because they weren't with us on the sidewalk,
and they couldn't see the exchange
that was happening between me and my crowd,
an exchange that was very fair to us but alien to them.
So this is slightly not safe for work.
This is my Kickstarter backer party in Berlin.
At the end of the night, I stripped and let everyone draw on me.
Now let me tell you, if you want to experience
the visceral feeling of trusting strangers --
(Laughter)
I recommend this,
especially if those strangers are drunk German people.
(Laughter)
This was a ninja master-level fan connection,
because what I was really saying here was,
I trust you this much.
Should I?
Show me.
For most of human history,
musicians, artists, they've been part of the community.
Connectors and openers, not untouchable stars.
Celebrity is about a lot of people loving you from a distance,
but the Internet
and the content that we're freely able to share on it
are taking us back.
It's about a few people loving you up close
and about those people being enough.
So a lot of people are confused by the idea
of no hard sticker price.
They see it as an unpredictable risk, but the things I've done,
the Kickstarter, the street, the doorbell,
I don't see these things as risk.
I see them as trust.
Now, the online tools
to make the exchange as easy and as instinctive as the street,
they're getting there.
But the perfect tools aren't going to help us
if we can't face each other
and give and receive fearlessly,
but, more important --
to ask without shame.
My music career has been spent
trying to encounter people on the Internet the way I could on the box.
So blogging and tweeting not just about my tour dates
and my new video but about our work and our art
and our fears and our hangovers,
our mistakes,
and we see each other.
And I think when we really see each other,
we want to help each other.
I think people have been obsessed with the wrong question,
which is, "How do we make people pay for music?"
What if we started asking,
"How do we let people pay for music?"
Thank you.
(Applause)